[Music]
black panther fans finally have an
answer to how the beloved franchise once
led by chadwick boseman will continue
within the marvel cinematic universe
during disney's 2020 investor day
presentation which featured news about a
slew of marvel centric movies and
streaming projects
marvel studios president and marvel
entertainment chief creative officer
kevin feige finally revealed at least
part of how the studio plans to move
forward following the death of bozeman
the lead in their most profitable
standalone film so far
the news which was later reconfirmed in
a tweet thread from the official disney
twitter account delivered marvel's final
decision on whether bozeman would be
recast as king t'challa and his
superhero alter-ego black panther
it's what many suspected and hoped for
all along
marvel isn't tapping another actor to
take bozeman's place in black panther 2.
disney's tweet read honoring chadwick
boseman's legacy and portrayal of
t'challa marvel studios will not recast
the character but will explore the world
of wakanda and the rich characters
introduced in the first film
there were no other details about how
the story will explore the world of
wakanda
but the mention of rich characters
seemingly hints towards the
long-discussed passing of the black
panther mantle
a character many marvelites are wishing
will rise to the occasion and become the
new black panther is t'challa's genius
sister shuri
played in the mcu by leticia wright
obviously there's a familial tie that
will make handing the black panther
mantle from t'challa to shuri both
logical and meaningful
not to mention the fact that it would
allow the brilliant inventor a chance to
bring wakanda even further into the
future with all of her gadgetry and tech
know-how
beyond that there's also precedent for
this mantle passing in the comic books
so marvel studios would have source
material to turn to
in the marvel comics shuri tries to duke
it out for the black panther mantle then
held by her uncle cyan but soon
discovers that t'challa already bested
him for the title
black panther vol 4 sees t'challa
training his younger sister and telling
her that she'd be able to put her skills
to use should there ever come a time
when she would need to succeed him as
the leader of wakanda
the next volume finds members of dr
doom's cabal coalition attacking
t'challa who slips into a coma
shuri carries on the necessary trials to
stake her claim to the black panther
mantle but she doesn't receive the
powers that come along with it when she
adjusts the heart-shaped earth due to
the jealousy she held against her
brother
it's only when shuri self-stylizes as
the black panther without having any of
its powers attempting to save her
brother and her country from an
attacking villain that she receives the
abilities
in addition to all that lore there's a
small but significant news report that
backs up the idea of wright shuri
possibly becoming the new black panther
in the upcoming sequel movie
for the hollywood reporter sources close
to marvel have said that quote
wright's character shuri may take on a
more prominent role in black panther 2.
of course that could simply mean she'll
be in more scenes have a larger
narrative arc take on new
responsibilities within the wakandan
government or all three
there's also a strong chance that marvel
could select no single character to be
the new black panther
instead opting to take the ryan coogler
written and directed film in a broader
direction and carry on the legacy of the
beloved superhero through multiple
characters
we simply won't know until black panther
2 hits theaters in 2022
the passing of bozeman was difficult for
the industry and fans alike
the actor had proven himself to be a
truly admirable person on and off screen
leveraging his fame to increase
co-star's pay and visiting young cancer
patients during their treatment
for many he was a real life hero which
has made the issue of whether to recast
t'challa a tough one for a studio
looking to carry on with its billion
dollar franchise
while many may take comfort in the fact
that marvel listened to their pleas to
not replace the late actor or recreate
bozeman's likeness
digitally they might be even happier to
know that their one and only t'challa
was able to get in one more marvel
appearance before his passing
it was previously thought that black
panther's return from the snap at the
end of 2019's avengers end game may have
been his last appearance in the mcu but
as the first trailer for the upcoming
disney plus animated series marvel's
what if confirms the king of wakanda had
another appearance set
and wildly it's not exactly as the black
panther the what-if series posits what
would happen to the mcu and its
characters if there were slight
variations in the timeline's events
in t'challa's case the trailer poses
what might have happened if michael
rooker's yondu had picked up the future
black panther from wakanda instead of
peter quill
the result it appears as a wakandan
star-lord the episode is sure to be
bittersweet
much like the black panther sequel when
it hits theaters on july 22nd 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one